up next is going to be Illinois Michele
is with us hi Michelle how are you hi um
I'm wondering how to get past powder but
syndrome I'll give you a story behind it
my parents are living in their home that
has no working toilet they've been that
way for at least nine months that I know
of they have to actually rent a little
blue house and instead of just fixing
this the tank they have gone on three
trips three little vacations is there
any way that you can recommend to
convince them that a working bathroom
might be more important than a vacation
that's past your responsibility that
sounds like mental illness well yes I
mean that's crazy
yes what do they make a year as far as I
know around 50 I think but they don't
they won't tell anybody they don't talk
to anybody about anything and you know
my brother and I've tried to deal with
this my sister kind of it's what they
want to do whatever strange people yes
we have an outhouse instead of a
vacation I mean wow we have a vacation
so that we have I mean because we at
home an unbelievable choices um yeah I
don't know um obviously they don't
you've tried to talk to them that they
don't mind being beyond strange um you
know that's not an issue for them they
think I'm really strange Doug yeah no
they're no no they're strange um it's
official I can put the label on it oh
man
uh well number one it is there right I
mean your sister has a point they can do
whatever they want it is that right
being strange is not illegal I suspect
that the helping department in the area
might have something to say about this
but yes because the
the tank is draining into their basement
my dad came and spent a night with me
and his luggage smelled horrible it was
awful
whoo yeah this is not eh this is past
range now it's not even healthy it's
going into the basement oh um nasty all
right their solution was put it on a
porter job so it's just water like from
the showers that goes in there yeah but
oh people in third world countries die
from this kind of stuff um that's what I
said yeah uh I I don't know I uh I think
this is a whole lot more than a
financial question you know and so I'm
not sure I'm qualified I mean I guess I
can answer it this way what would I do
um you know there's only so much you can
do to get somebody that's a grown up to
be that's so crazy that I can't even
know where to start well neither did do
i yeah and so I don't know I mean uh I'm
sure they're not involved in a church
are they oh yes they're active members
they my mom teaches Sunday School they
won't tell their church family that
they're in this kind of condition no
okay um why don't you tell their pastor
because May if she's active in Sunday
school maybe he has more influence with
them than you do but that's possible I
do live seven hours away and because I
moved away they don't want to talk to me
as much anymore well then you really
don't have any influence but yeah
for two reasons geography and that their
feelings are hurt about you leaving or
whatever so um yeah I think you know it
would be it I think you who can speak
into their life and maybe their pastor
can maybe he could you know just say you
know I don't know how just call him and
have the same conversation with him you
had with me
so I don't know how to deal with this
and I'm asking your advice and I don't
know pastor maybe you could swing by and
talk to them about this because this is
like you know it's a poor reflection on
that church that somebody that just nuts
is teaching Sunday school they haven't
been this way for I mean this is kind of
a newer thing and it's like it's getting
worse it's not about you
it's not that new when septic is running
in your basement new is an hour okay new
is an hour not six months while I went
on two vacations that's not new this is
just oh my god no you know no I don't
think you're you know you you it for
their sake they need to address
whatever's going on in their brain here
and then they'll address the financial
issue but this is just out of whack and
yeah they don't that lady doesn't need
to be teaching Sunday School she's nuts
you know I don't I don't want some of no
yeah yeah and I'm not calling the pastor
to get her fired from Sunday school
that's not the point the point is I'm
calling because he may have some
influence to help her get some get his
arm around them and say listen folks
y'all just can't do this and you know
get in you know they teach the Financial
Peace University class at that church
probably and he can probably get them
into one of the classes and I'll be
happy to give them a class but I don't
think they're going to take that from
you or me because you and me just sit
and talked about in front of 12 million
people but that's what I'm going to have
somebody intersect their life that has
influence with them and you don't that's
what you're running into and so so wild
wild wild well some people's children
some people's parents hey guys Rachael
Cruz here hope you enjoyed that video
from the Dave Ramsey show if you want to
watch another great video check out my
video three things you should consider
renting right over here or click the
link in the description below